hi everyone
I'm happy to be here
what if I told you that each and every
one of us is harboring an endless
treasure in our own home
every day we go about our lives crooked
meals
spending time with loved ones and
leaving behind traces of ourselves in
the form of the dust in our home
Crumbs from the food we ate and smoke
residue from our cooking
fibers from our clothes hair and nail
fragments skin cells laundry and perfume
other molecules pets dander pollen fungi
minerals man-made pollution the
combination of these elements can be as
unique as a fingerprint
like pictures dust samples can only
provide a snapshot of a specific moment
in time but while pictures represent
visually dust contain material evidence
that opens more deciphering
opportunities
the science behind the dust is well
known archeology microbiology
allergology forensic and environmental
science
as we pair it with the length dust
reveals itself as a detailed story
at this point I got excited not only by
the material itself but also by the
combination of the two concepts of dust
in-house
dust is a concept rich in cultural and
social myth throughout human history
cloth in hand we erase proofs of our
mortality wrote the philosopher Michael
model
the dust breeding photographed by Man
Ray resonance the dust's superpower to
conceal and reveal simultaneously
the concept of home is long time
embedded in human behavior
it can be seen as the foundation upon
which every other aspect of human life
is built
home is embedded into the physicality of
the house
that's from one house tells the story of
people
dust from several houses tells the story
of a city
thus from several cities tells the story
of a country and continents
so what are we going to do with all
these valuable information thrown under
our feet
the dust project collects a million dust
samples from homes worldwide in a short
period of time
through a global multilingual
edutainment campaign
it yields three distinct archives that
offer a comprehensive view of human
activity in the environment over time
and a one-of-a-kind public experience of
shared testimony
an advanced digital platform enables you
to register free of charge based on
geolocation you will receive a
state-of-the-art envelope-sized dust
collection kit delivered to your
doorstep
in the week between receiving the kit
and taking the sample you might want to
bake your favorite cookies wear a shirt
with sentimental value or invite your
parents over
then with a collection sticker swipe
around areas of the house to get a
meaningful sample
your sample will be divided to three
parts to establish the dust archives
the mission of the archives is to create
a framework that enables the active
participation of the public in research
and education projects
the first archive consists of samples
kept by the participants at the home it
will serve as a personal connection
between them and the project for current
and future research as well as a unique
family heirloom
the second archive is hosted in a museum
it will serve as a more centralized and
and accessible data source and will
offer multiple ways to engage with the
project findings by the General Public
third archives is stored inside the dust
Arc around passive satellite in the
shape of the Earth placed in orbit 2 000
kilometer altitude from Earth as a
future archaeological artifact
with a 1.4 meter in diameter and a
highly reflective exterior duster can be
seen from Earth with regular telescopes
and it will stay in its orbit for at
least a century
maybe one day the arc will reach
futuristic deciphering technologies that
will recreate moments including tastes
smells and textures
if Humanity or the Earth will
dramatically change we may be leaving
behind not only names and pictures but
also a tangible experience from our life
story
thank you
[Applause]